thank you
and last night after SAG Awards the
stars were out in full Glam Sally Field
and Andrew Garfield were the cutest Duo
as he presented His Amazing Spider-Man
co-star Aunt May with the Lifetime
Achievement Award you never drink the
Kool-Aid of your own brilliance
you never get high on your own Supply
is it okay if I leave for a minute no
you pay tribute to her tonight oh my God
it was responsible for me she's like I'm
not sorry some kind of surrogate
something in my life I don't know we
created a bond we can't it was a
relationship that just continues the
minute we see each other he's like can I
help you are you okay do you want to
stay I think we need you guys in another
project together
I've been lucky enough to be a part of
so many films still Magnolias was so fun
it was a hole in my life until I met
them really Mrs Doubtfire or Forest life
is a box of chocolates fullest that the
group the actors together
are so great to be around you just don't
want to go home at night well that's not
true you do want to go home at night
like is it over yet can we get out of
here this year marks the 30th
anniversary of Mrs Doubtfire have you
noticed that you're lying the whole time
has taken on a new life on the internet
the whole time my mouth the whole time
you would eat the whole time I said it
four times four different ways for a
different time yeah you see it so it was
a comedic moment of course on the way to
the stage Sally got an assist from
Austin Butler so did Winner Jennifer
Coolidge are you used to this by now
Jennifer
no I mean as you can see I wasn't you so
I didn't you know and I couldn't even
put a sense together tonight I you know
you know all right yeah this was
unexpected an emotional Jennifer said
you know 20 times in Her speech but when
the White Lotus won drama series
Ensemble Focus turned to hurt turns
co-star I am a little bit drunk I'm
small and I'm a lightweight
losing her balance guzzling bubbly
straight from the bottle and kissing her
co-star Haley Lou Richardson and a
Smoochy Theo James made their first time
sag award wins count there's a lot of
love in this cast huh yeah yeah That's
Amore we should find the people who did
this
are you in Jenna Ortega up there I think
we need a buddy cop comedy or something
I'm down we'll just kill everybody with
our eyes
Aubry photo bombed her way into this
Parks and Rec reunion between Adam Scott
and Amy Poehler and we're not the only
ones hoping for an Amy Amanda Seyfried
reunion in the Mean Girls musical movie
you know I'm still hoping for a miracle
but you're so in right all four of us
are 100 Amanda actually auditioned to
play Regina George screen testing with
Lindsay Lohan and a then unknown star
who almost played Karen Blake Lively I
was just like who's this gorgeous woman
I was just like yeah perfect I was so
game duh I started September of 2003 and
I would have been going to college so if
I hadn't gotten this role I would have
had to take some courses and it's worth
it
as for Lilo she wants Gus to us about
these co-stars who got back together
last night Elaine and then there's Lisa
everyone's so nice this is a moment a
Parent Trap reunion at the SAG Awards it
took her 19 hours to get here because of
the weather I was determined she asked
me to be her date I showed up as her
date Jamie Lee Curtis had reunions and
everything everywhere all at once
ET was with her right after she accepted
her very first sag award Jamie Lee
Curtis
I'm wearing the wedding ring that my
father gave to my mother
they hated each other by the way at the
end
I just put it on because I thought I'd
bring them with me you had made a joke
at the beginning of the show my father
Tony Curtis nepo baby
I'm not gonna pretend that there was no
effect of having them as my parents but
I'm 64 years old I've been an actress
since I was 19. Jamie's winning moment
happened so fast she forgot she planted
a bagel kiss on her co-star Michelle yo
I kissed her did I really I kissed her I
love Michelle yo we fell in love with
each other
[Music]
Michelle and Costa are kihui Kwan both
made history as the first Asian actors
to win in their categories right before
their movie took home the biggest Award
of the night outstanding performance by
a cast in a motion picture when you have
your peers reach out and say we love
what you do that's the biggest
compliment this moment no longer belongs
to just me
it also belongs to everyone who has
asked for change
I mean you could have predicted that you
would be in this conversation as the
same year as your Encino Man co-star
Brendan Fraser that's what made this
season so special reuniting with Brendan
Fraser of course and then Steven
Spielberg it just makes it so much
memorable believe me if you just stay in
there and you put one foot in front of
the other
you'll get to where you need to go
an emotional Brendan made it a date
night with his girlfriend Jeannie he
beat out Elvis's Austin Butler who was
there with his dad and hustles Adam
Sandler who took pics with his wife
Jackie love those Smiles love those
smiles from Biola Davis and Julius
tennen to nisi Nash Bets with wife
Jessica Hollywood couples came to play
and slick we all got to get someone to
look at us the way John Krasinski looks
at Emily Blunt in her red hot floral
bandage dress yeah together y'all look
so lovely just for the record Emily
presented with Ozark's Jason Bateman
before his big win thank you to my wife
Amanda I'm just really really thankful
that I had so many good people around to
help me not uh stumble on my face people
like Laura Linney and Julie Garner I
would have had to really screw up to uh
make it make it a disaster also honored
Sam affiliate for the Yellowstone
prequel 1883. thank you to Paramount and
thank you to my wife my beautiful
Catherine my partner through thick and
thin I can't imagine
any more special acknowledgment of my
work and come on Abbott Elementary
winning for outstanding ensemble in a
cup there oh my God he's my support
system I mean I would not be able to do
any I feel like I should have did the
thank you up there but I don't know if I
was overwhelmed y'all he knows no that's
the support system I mean a partner
during all of this
you can't buy that kind of support
[Music]
foreign